توزعت سبعه افلام عربيه على مسابقات
مهرجان كان السينما الدولي بدورته لهذا
العام حيث يشارك لاول مره في تاريخ
المهرجان الفيلم السوداني وداعا جوليا
للمخرج محمد كردفاني تدور احداث الفيلم في
الخرطوم وقبيله انفصال الجنوب وينتمي الى
الدراما الاجتماعيه مع جانب تشويقيا بطابع
مستلهم من السينما الواقعيه
فيلم يمثل المغرب للمخرجه اسماء المدير
يحمل عنوان كذب ابيض ويتحدث عن سيرتها
الذاتيه من خلال صوره تعثر عليها وهي مع
مجموعه اطفال في الدار البيضاء وتعود بها
ذكريات الى تفاصيل واحداث مرت بها وعن بعض
الاكاذيب التي سمعتها من جدتها لكنها كانت
اكاذي بيضاء هو بدا بصوره انا كل حكاياتي
التي حكيتها او ساحكيها تبدا من منطلق
صوره واحده هي بالصدفه لكن كذب ابيض ايضا
انطلق من صوره صوره قدمتها لوالدتي عن
طفولتي
في المسابقه الرسميه بنات الفه للمخرج
كوثر بن هنيه ويعالج قصه حقيقيه عن اربع
بنات للام الفا يتم اغراؤهن للعمل مع
المنظمات الارهابيه وهو فيلم درامي وثائقي
فيلم مغربي اخر للمخرج كما الازرق يشارك
في المسابقه الثانيه في المهرجان ويحمل
عنوان كلاب الصيد ويتحدث هذا الفيلم عن
حسن وعصام الابن والاب ويح
اليومي في احدى رواح الدار البيضاء
ويقومانى باعمال خارج القانون لصالح هذا
المتنفذين ويحاولان ايجاد حل لمشكلتهما
جزء من المجتمع المغربي الذي لا يوجد حلول
ماديا
ويبحث عن
مشاريع خطيره كما سيعرض المهرجان فيلم
ببساطه مثل سيلفان للمخرج التونسيه
الكنديه منى شكري وهناك افلام اخرى خارج
المسابقه منها فيلم من الجزائر عمر
الفراوله ويروي الفيلم قصه الرجل عصابات
تجبره الظروف على الفرار من فرنسا الى
وطنه الجزائر ويحكم عليه بالسجن لمده
عشرين عاما في الجزائر هذا العام الحضور
العربي في مهرجان كان هو الابرز سبعه
افلام في المسابقات الرسميه وشخصيات اخرى
توزعت على لجنه التحكيم سعد المسعودي
العربيه مهرجان كان السينمائي جنوب فرنسا
متابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات